I'm Dwight Wiest, Scoutmaster with Troop 17 at Yakota Air Base, Japan.
This edition of the Scoutmaster podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
And now for you, Scoutmaster,
This week we're going to start with a riddle from John Dyer.
He said the joke at the start of the podcast is one of the best parts.
Oh, I'm still having a good time telling those jokes to my
scouts. I wanted to send you this riddle:
What's black when you get it red when you use it and gray when you throw it away?
Hmm, I have to give that some thought
And I will tell you the answer, folks, after we've gone a wandering for a little bit.
So this is podcast number 266..
Yeah,
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Green.
What's the answer to John Dyer's riddle?
What's black when you get it red when you use it, gray when you throw it away?
You probably figured it out by now, but it's charcoal.
There you go,
It's yours to use and be fuddle and confuse and horrify your scouts.
Let's take a look at the mailbag here
Heard from Gary Miller in Emmett, Idaho.
He said I just wanted you to know I finally caught up with all the podcasts.
Thank you so much for all you do
Well. thank you, Gary.
My congratulations to anybody who makes it through all 266 podcasts.
Good for you.
I heard from Martin Ornberg, who is an assistant council commissioner
with the Greater Alabama Council.
He says I was turned on to your podcast by Randall Cox in April of this year
And we're both unit commissioners and we live in Huntsville, Alabama.
I am also the council champion for commissioner tools
And I'm discovering most scouts know about my scoutingorg
since they took their youth protection training there,
But they may not be familiar with the newer site, my dot scoutingorg.
The new site allows all scouts to see what positions they're registered in,
Print membership cards and change and update their email and their phone
or their address.
They can also see their training and view announcements and calendars
native to my dot scoutingorg
And I have prepared a PDF info sheet that shows you exactly how it works
And thank you, Martin,
We've made people aware of it.
You may be used to my scoutingorg
But there's another site that is my dot scoutingorg.
It's got another dot in it
And Martin has a helpful guide that he created in the way of a PDF document
And I'll have a link to it in the post that contains this podcast over on the blog
This past week had a couple of posts that relate to the theme
that's been going on with our source code of scouting.
One of them was a post of a very early Green Bar Bill article.
It might be the first one that he wrote in Scouting Magazine in 1927
called a troop revolution,
And I recommend that to you highly.
You want to make sure to check that out.
Another post that I put up this past week posed the question:
why do Scouts go camping?
There was a lot of useful discussion about that on Facebook too.
So when you get the chance, make sure, if you haven't read those posts already,
get over to scoutmastercgcom and check them out.
The live chat over on scoutmastercgcom was pretty lively this week.
Watch the Facebook feed and the Twitter feed or just stop by scoutmastercgcom,
Check out the chat feature, see if we're on there live chatting,
And we've. we've had some pretty big groups check in with us these past couple of weeks,
In addition to all the folks I call my frequent fliers who check in frequently on the chat.
we heard from Mike Waite, who's an assistant scout master in Pennsylvania.
Glenn Dardy is a committee chair of Troop 17 in Gibstown, New Jersey.
Michael Cotter, who is with PAC 41 in Columbus, Ohio,
Arthur Doncey, who is an assistant scout master in Egg Harbor, New Jersey.
William Schmidt, who is a scout master from Troop 204 in Cary, North Carolina.
Atia Santos, who is a scout master in Espirito Santo, Brazil.
And Keith Kangry, who is a scout master with Troop 2 in Picayune, Mississippi.
It's great to be able to get together and chat a little bit,
And sometimes the discussion is is deep and meaningful
And sometimes it's just kind of hanging out with your scout buddies.
So make sure to stop by scoutmastercgcom and check that out.
Now I want to let you know that everything at scoutmastercgcom
is there to help scouters, but to keep everything freely available,
I depend on people like you to become backers.
It's an unusual idea,
So let me explain it for a moment.
If I was sending you a paper magazine or newsletter,
you'd expect there to be some costs associated with that, right?
I'd need to pay printers and writers and postage and all of that.
What happens these days is a little more ephemeral.
It's all in bits and bytes. right,
I don't send out a printed newspaper or a newsletter.
I put posts online and I have a podcast.
It's similar, because somebody spends their time producing the content
and incurs the expenses of publishing it online.
And backers are the folks who make a one time voluntary subscription payment,
And the money that we get from them covers the expenses of producing
and publishing what you find on scoutmastercgcom,
including what you're listening to right now.
So here's what I would like you to do:
Go to scoutmastercgcom, click the support link at the top of the page
and you'll find a number of options that will make you a scoutmastercgcom backer,
And I want to take a moment to thank Agnes Monzingo,
who became a backer since our last podcast.
Go over to scoutmastercgcom this week. become a backer.
I'll make sure to thank you personally in our next podcast.
Well, on this week's podcast, we've got one big feature,
and that is the final installment of a three part series
on the scouting source code.
This final installment is a little bit longer than the first two
And I think it's plenty of information to fill up the remainder of this podcast.
I'll have answers to lots and lots of backlogged email questions
next time around in podcast 267.
But I'm excited about the concept that there is a source code to scouting
And I'm very excited to share it with you.
So let's get started, shall we?
So we've been following the story of Green Bar Bill Hillcourt, with the idea of getting
to what I've called the source code of scouting, the DNA,
the thing that makes scouting what it is,
The focus that we should all know by heart and that we should be paying attention to.
If we could come up with that right
And everyone agreed that this is where we're headed,
This is our aim,
This is what we do,
Then we'd be better able to serve the scouts that we serve, correct?
Let me get you caught up.
This three part series is based on a recording that I found in the Internet
archive that has. there's really no way for me to give it any better attribution
than it There it is. It was just kind of sitting there.
Everything that I can figure out with this recording indicates that it was
in the late 1980s. It's an interview
A scout is conducting with Green Bar Bill and he has told us the story
of how he became a scout before there was all of this organizational
stuff happening in scouting, because he got a copy of Scouting for Boys
in 1910. He put a patrol together and part one of this explains exactly
how that all happened. He traveled to the United States.
He became involved with the Boy Scouts of America, and he ended up
being the voice of the Boy Scouts of America.
He had written all of the major reference materials for the Boy Scouts
of America based on his understanding of scouting.
This source code idea is not to turn back the clock
and not to make us a bunch of stodgy old traditionalists who are
basically just conducting, you know, some kind of historic
reenactment of the first Brown Sea Island encampment with
Baden Powell. That's not our aim,
That's not what we're trying to do.
But what were the principles underlying the whole idea that
Bill took on when he was a boy, at age 10, and then elucidated
in all the writing and all the work that he did over his lifetime?
Why is it still relevant today?
We're a century later, you know. why is it still relevant?
Because if we agree that it's relevant and we get a hold of
that source code, that's pretty powerful.
That's something that we can really take and run with right
To introduce today's installment of this story
OK, and to kind of wind it up,
And because I really love the history of these sorts of things.
Before I play this, though, here's a couple of things
that will help you understand it better.
Bill is now married.
He actually married one of the secretaries at the BSA offices.
Her name is Grace
And they are living at the Schiff Scout Reservation in New Jersey
And Bill has established a troop- troop number one in New Jersey
And he's using that troop kind of his his lab- to develop things.
Anyway, that'll just help you understand a couple of things in this story.
Let's let Bill explain for a little while his relationship
with Baden Powell, the founder of Scouting.
He knew Baden Powell
In 1935, Baden Powell and this wife who was the chief girl scout.
they took a trip around the world and they had planned to be at the
First National Jamboree we had in 1935.
The one that was canceled because of the polio outbreak in Virginia.
And then he came out to the Schiff Scout Reservation.
So I had Baden Powell and Lady Baden Powell in my house
And we had a wonderful time with breakfast and so on.
But then what happened was that we went to the Jamboree and Holland in 1937.
When we got out there and out that the whole hotel has been taken over
by the British Jamboree contingent staff,
Next morning we, as we opened the door-
How's another one of these complete coincidence of meeting the right people
at the right time, Lady Baden Powell and Baden Powell
coming up the corridor.
They had just arrived from England and they just come to the hotel
And Lady Baden Powell saw them, saw us, and said: Oh, it's Bill and Grace.
And he said: Well, have you had your breakfast?
No, we haven't had our breakfast.
Well, you just wait a while until we get ourselves settled.
So the two hillcourts had breakfast with the two big powers.
So, and on the basis of that, of course they are right.
So he came to the point of getting so close to Lady Baden Powell
that when I wanted to take Baden Powell's books
and transform them into World Brotherhood editions
for starting scouting up again around the world after the World War,
he gave me a permission to just take Baden Powell's book and edit them
And they are now the official versions of the Baden Powell Scouting for Boys
and Asian Scout Masters.
So there's the basis of a very close relationship
between the Baden Powell's and the hillcourts.
And Baden Powell passes away in 1941, just a few years after this meeting.
As Bill explained, he becomes the editor
of the official publications of Baden Powell's works
after the Second World War,
And I know this is unraveling a little bit like a mystery.
but look at all the connections.
One of the original scouts in 1910 in Denmark becomes
the voice of the Boy Scouts of America,
has a relationship with the founder of Scouting
that is close enough to allow him to edit his works.
So where is the source code?
Where exactly is it expressed?
Well, Bill has an answer for that
And it comes in his answer to this question.
What do you think Baden Powell would say?
What was his point in doing all that?
Well, I think what he would do is he would pretty well have page nine
in mind, because that was completely based upon Baden Powell.
And what trouble writing that page and any other page,
Because I wanted on one page to be able to say:
well, this is what Scouting is all about.
This is the wonderful life you would have in Scouting.
You will learn a lot of different skills,
You will meet good friends and you will have a chance to even learn leadership and so on.
And we're going to need real leaders
with that kind of a spirit in the future,
and even more than we have ever needed them before.
In order to do that, you have to show the example of that,
because you have to take on the role model of becoming a good scout,
living up to the scout oath and the scout law
and following all of the principles of Scouting.
If you get yourself really involved in all of these things-
and that's the important thing, getting yourself involved-
Don't be a passive person there
and then step in and help other people at all times.
You see, that's another part of the scout idea,
because he believed in all people getting together
and helping each other in a real friendship.
So I think he will stick to this general idea.
Of course, that's right out of it now.
So now we know where the source code is.
It's on page nine. page nine of what you ask.
Well, I'm going to tell you, but think about this
Again, remembering all the connections
that we've made over this three-part series.
We get to the question of what was Baden Powell up to?
Why did he do all this in the first place?
Well, Bill says it's on page nine.
Here's a guy who's got this tremendous amount of writing
that he's done over his lifetime
And he says this was the most challenging page I ever wrote,
because he wanted to boil it down
to the source code of Scouting.
To better explain how page nine came to be,
we need to understand what happened in the early 1970s
that brought Bill out of retirement,
where he donated a year of his time
to rewrite the Scouting handbook.
What you're going to hear is Bill speaking
in a video, actually, that I've shared on the blog before
And I'll have a link to that video in the post
that contains this podcast, where he's visiting
with some Scouts and Scouters in Florida in 1987.
And he explains what happened
and how he ended up coming up with page nine
And, by way of explanation
to preface what Bill's going to say,
give you a little context here.
So in the early 1970s,
the Boy Scouts of America initiates a study of Scouting
that has some what will become
pretty much disastrous results
And Bill tells us a little bit about that
and his reaction to it.
It had to be brought up to date.
That was a big thing in those days
And it had to be relevant.
So they came up with a suggestion
that we should change it completely.
There's too much emphasis about the outer doors,
The people in the National
Architectural Development stuff,
that we started lowering all the expectations
or whatever first class Scouts should be.
He didn't have to be an outdoorsman,
As a matter of fact, when we started the Skill Award.
you only had to take three Skill Awards
for ten to put three Skill Awards in a second class.
three Skill Awards,
You could pick your own.
And I insisted that we should have at least hiking
and for second class
and we should have camping for first class,
because this idea of becoming first class
without having a camp was rather silly.
That's why the membership went down from six million
to more than a half million.
Then I started to wonder:
is the Boy Scouts sales going down
Because my last handbook that came out
up until 1970 was selling 600,000 copies a year.
In seven years it had dropped to about 340,000.
And the same is going down
because the membership is going down?
Or is it the other way around,
that the membership is going down
because a Boy Scout handbook
doesn't tell the story
about how much excitement you can have as a scout?
So I decided to put a year of my life on the line
and I suggested to them
I'll write you another Boy Scout handbook for your job.
That Boy Scout handbook came out
on the 8th of February 1979..
Will you open the page?
What edition is it?
What printing is it? sir?
I believe this one is the ninth edition,
And will you see how many have been printed
on that particular edition,
No ninth edition.
Three million four million fifty thousand.
How many?
We have printed more than three million copies
of this since this book came out.
Will you turn to page nine
in all of your books
When you go home?
I don't want you to do it right here,
But the thing that's happening out in your camp.
we have a training group there of 64 men
from all over this whole region
And there are 17 leaders,
including the National Director of Boy Scouting,
the National Director of Training,
the National Director of Research.
They're part of the training group out here
because the Hillcourt has been yelling
about the fact that Scoutmasters should be trained
to make every single promise on page nine
come true in the lives of your kids.
So that recording. there was a lot of noise in it
and I did my best.
I'm not an audio engineer, obviously,
but I did my best to clean it up a little bit
and it may be a little difficult to understand.
So let me reiterate:
This study happens.
The Scouting program changes radically
because they want to update everything
and they think, oh, this outdoor stuff is old hat,
Boys aren't attracted to that,
And so we're gonna change things around
and we're gonna make it more theoretical,
We're going to try and make things more palatable.
We're gonna get rid of a lot of this outdoor emphasis.
So Bill volunteers a year of his time
to rewrite the Scout Handbook in the late 70s,
and the product of that year
is the ninth edition of the Boy Scout Handbook.
And on the mysterious page nine- that's where it is-
It's in the ninth edition of the Boy Scout Handbook
And, as we've learned through all the connections
through this series, there's the source code of Scouting.
So what is on page nine?
What did the voice of the Boy Scouts of America,
the guy who knew Baden Powell,
the guy who became a Scout just about as soon
as anybody in the world could become a Scout
And who wrote about Scouting for his entire life?
what was the most challenging thing for him to do
was to reduce it to one page,
and it's page nine of the ninth edition
of the Boy Scout Handbook.
So what exactly does that page say?
I'm gonna read it to you right now,
because it's a quick read,
and it's titled Your Life as a Scout.
You're an American boy
and before long you'll be an American man.
It's an important to America and to yourself
that you become a citizen of fine character,
physically strong, mentally awake and morally straight.
Boy Scouting will help you become that kind of citizen.
but also Scouting will give you fellowship and fun.
Yes, it's fun to be a Boy Scout.
It's fun to go hiking and camping with your best friends,
to swim, to dive, to paddle a canoe, to wield an axe,
to follow the footsteps of the pioneers
who led the way through the wilderness,
to stare into the glowing embers of a campfire
and dream the wonders of the life
that is in store for you.
It's also fun to learn to walk noiselessly through the woods,
to stalk close to a grazing deer without being noticed,
to bring a bird close to you by imitating its call.
It's fun to find your way, cross country by map and compass,
to make a meal when you're hungry,
to take a safe swim when you're hot,
to make yourself comfortable for the night
in a tent under the stars.
In Scouting you become an outdoorsman.
but Scouting is far more than fun in the outdoors,
hiking and camping.
Scouting is a way of life.
Scouting is growing into a responsible manhood,
learning to be of service to others.
The Scout Oath and the Scout Law
are your guides to citizenship.
They tell you what is expected of a Scout.
They point out your duties.
The Scout motto is: be prepared-
prepared to take care of yourself
and to help other people in need.
The Scout slogan is: do a good turn daily
Together. the motto and slogan spell out your ability
and your willingness to serve.
Your life as a Scout will make you strong and self-reliant.
You'll learn Scoutcraft skills
that will benefit you as you grow
and in time, you'll develop the skills
of leadership as well.
So pitch in, swing into action
In your patrol and your troop.
you'll have some of the best times of your life.
I can't put it any better.
I doubt anybody could.
What a wonderful challenge
and what a wonderful description
of exactly what Scouting is,
The DNA of Scouting, the source code of Scouting.
Scouting is fun in the outdoors,
but it's more than just that fun.
It is a way of life
that you'll grow into, a responsible human being.
That's the source code,
That's what we need to be thinking about,
That's what we need to understand
and we need to apply as Scouters
to serve the youth that we're serving.
Wherever you are in the world, it's gonna work.
However, things have changed and morphed
and gotten different in our cultures and societies,
the source code is still going to work.
However much training and policy and procedure
and organizational craziness there is out there,
the source code is still going to work.
That's what Scouting really is.
Now take that, take that page nine,
take that source code and make it a reality.
That's what Bill said. he wants Scouters to be trained
to make those things a reality in the lives of their Scouts.
He understands and he explains to the Scouts
that, yes, this is going to be a lot of fun
and it's challenging and it's gonna be great,
but there's an ulterior motive,
because it's a way of life
that helps you grow into a responsible human being.
There's no secret code.
there's no step one, two, three. for Scouters,
The challenge is to take that page nine
and make it a reality in the life of your Scouts.
and it's simple. it's very, very simple
And I'm reminded of something that Baden Powell said:
it's like swinging a scythe or a golf club:
Very, very simple. anybody can do it,
but it takes a lifetime of practice to get good at it.
So that's our job, that's everything that we do.
Get good at the source code,
get good at making it happen in the lives of your Scouts.
That's the only thing that ends up really mattering.
How to test if what you're doing as a Scouter
is advancing the aims of Scouting is to read page nine.
Are you making that happen?
Then you're successful.
Are you realizing that ulterior motive
in the lives of the young people you're serving?
Then you're successful. Scouter.
That's the source code.
It's as important as it is simple,
And it's a huge challenge for us to see
in that simplicity exactly what we're up to
and the way that Scouting works.
Listen to this 266th edition of the Scoutmaster podcast
By going to the blog at ScoutmasterCgcom.
you can subscribe to receive updates,
blog by email And you can join all the other mobile scouts who have the Scoutmaster CG app
on their mobile devices. You can get the app on Google Player, on the iTunes app store.
You can experience the wonders of ScoutmasterCGcom through the vast panorama of social media
outlets. You can join over 8,800 folks who like Scoutmaster blogging on Facebook. You can tweet
along with a course of 1,200 tweeters on Twitter. Pin the Pultritudinous Pictures proffered
publicly with 2,000 other prolific pinners on Pinterest. Watch us at ScoutmasterCG on YouTube
And, of course, join the 500 odd folks who form the exclusive Scoutmaster CG circle on Google Plus.
Now, if none of that makes any sense to you at all, if you can't face Facebook,
if Twitter makes you bitter, if you've no interest in Pinterest, if you don't put the?
U in YouTube, if you're a minus when it comes to Google Plus, don't worry about it.
Zoom into the late 90s and send me an email. Yep, you can get in touch with me the old
fashion way. Email me, Clark Green, with your comments and questions at Clark at ScoutmasterCGcom.
It's C-L-A-R-K-E at ScoutmasterCGcom. You may have grown tired of hearing this, but
I need to tell you something. The Scoutmaster blog and the Scoutmaster podcast are not
official publications of anybody other than myself. We're not official publications of Boy
Scouts of America. We're not endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America. It's just me
talking into a microphone, trying to lend a hand to Scoutleaders and have a little bit of fun here
and there. And speaking of a little bit of fun, here's our founder, Sir Robert Bidden Powell. Sir
Robert, Good luck to you and good camping. Why? thank you, sir, Until next time, everyone.